They're often billed as "family-friendly."
But sometimes, television shows designed for
young audiences contain some really dark and
twisted stuff.
With plots involving depression, abandonment,
and all kinds of real-world horrors, it's
amazing that some of these episodes ever made
it on the air.
Here are some of the worst offenders.
The Fairly Odd Parents - It's a Wishful Life
From the opening moments of this episode,
things go downhill fast.
Timmy, the main character, keeps trying to
do good deeds, but nobody appreciates his
efforts, even his loved ones.
Understandably upset, he wishes that he'd
never been born — a wish that his fairy
godparent Wanda reluctantly grants.
In a parody of It's a Wonderful Life — you
know, the beloved Christmas movie about offing
yourself...
"So you still think killing yourself would
make everyone feel happier, right?"
"Well, I dunno, I guess you're right."
...Timmy sees what the world would be like
without him.
However, unlike the movie, Timmy discovers
that everyone he knows is much happier if
he's not around.
Even more troubling, Timmy is later shown
the hellish place where all the kids who wished
they were never born go, implying that this
sort of thing happens on a regular basis.
Later, Jorgen von Strangle explains that the
whole thing was a setup, aimed at teaching
a lesson — The lesson that you can't even
trust your fairy godparents, especially if
you're going through a tough time in your
life.
Boy Meets World - Cult Fiction
ABC's coming-of-age sitcom Boy Meets World
didn't shy away from difficult subjects, but
one episode tops them all: season four's "Cult
Fiction."
Thanks to his turbulent home life, Shawn frequently
struggles with loneliness and abandonment
issues, and that makes him a perfect mark
for a local cult that targets troubled kids.
Before long, he's hopelessly brainwashed by
the cult's leader, Mr. Mack.
Later, Shawn's teacher Mr. Turner, who served
as a sort of surrogate father to him, is involved
in a bad motorcycle wreck and is hospitalized.
Unable to cope with the situation, Shawn brings
Mr. Mack to the hospital with him, where Cory's
father and Principal Feeny have a confrontation
with the cult leader:
"Now you brought Shawn down, thanks, now why
don't you just take a hike back to Conland."
"Now do you see how judgemental these people
are ---"
"No, no, listen!"
Meanwhile, Cory and Topanga bring Shawn to
Mr. Turner's room and force him to confront
the reality of their teacher's condition head-on,
leading to an emotional monologue where Shawn
talks directly to God:
"Don't blow me off, John.
Don't blow me off, God!
I've never asked you for anything and I never
wanted to come to you like this."
Rugrats - Angelica's Worst Nightmare
If you grew up watching Rugrats, you might
not have been aware of the heavy themes.
But as an adult, you'll soon notice some really
tragic backstories that go unnoticed by the
babies.
The darkest episode, though, is "Angelica's
Worst Nightmare."
Angelica Pickles enjoys her status as a spoiled
only child, so when her mother announces that
she's pregnant, Angelica's fragile ego is
thrown into a tailspin.
Her parents ignore her while discussing the
pregnancy, and Angelica begins to worry that
they won't have time for her.
In a nightmare, Angelica's baby brother has
arrived, and her parents have forgotten who
she is, forcing her to live in the laundry
room and eat table scraps.
After taking everything she loves, the gigantic
baby chases Angelica out of the house before
catching her and starting to eat the car — which
causes her to wake up, screaming.
Later, Angelica's parents tell her that they
aren't going to have a baby after all, and
while she feigns disappointment, Angelica
is secretly pleased about the sad news.
The Powerpuff Girls - Twisted Sister
In The Powerpuff Girls episode "Twisted Sister,"
the trio of cute cartoon superheroes find
themselves overwhelmed with school, chores,
and constantly saving the day.
They decide to create a fourth Powerpuff Girl
to help share the load.
But instead of following the Professor's original
formula of sugar, spice, and everything nice,
the girls use artificial sweetener, dirt,
and things like crayons, lizards, and boxing
gloves — along with the secret ingredient,
Chemical X.
The result is a gigantic, misshapen, and not
very bright new Powerpuff Girl that they name
Bunny.
Unfortunately, Bunny mixes things up — throwing
police officers in jail while letting the
criminals run free.
When her sisters arrive, they angrily tell
Bunny that she's bad and can't be a Powerpuff
Girl.
Heartbroken, Bunny flies away to sob her heart
out on a lonely cliffside, but returns when
her sisters are in danger to defeat all the
bad guys, excited that she's finally been
"good."
Unfortunately, this effort was too much for
Bunny's unstable body, and she explodes.
A piece of her dress flutters to the ground,
and the girls cry as they realize how awful
they were.
Even the narrator of the show can barely handle
it.
"It's so sad, I can't take it."
Tom & Jerry - Blue Cat Blues
In stark contrast to the typical slapstick
antics found in the classic cartoon Tom & Jerry,
the 1956 feature "Blue Cat Blues" has an extremely
tragic — and traumatizing — plot.
Tom falls in love with a beautiful white cat.
But although she returns his affections at
first, she eventually leaves Tom for a rich
neighborhood cat named Butch.
Jerry tells Tom to move on with his life,
but Tom can't let go, and eventually literally
sells himself into slavery to buy her a car:
"It cost him an arm and a leg, but he willingly
sold himself into slavery… for love."
— which promptly gets destroyed by Butch's
fancy coupe.
Heartbroken and hopelessly in debt, Tom turns
to the bottle — the milk bottle, that is
— and decides to sit down on the train tracks
and end it all once the two cats get married.
Jerry, at a loss on how to cheer up his friend,
consoles himself that at least his own girlfriend
wouldn't do that to him.
Just then, Jerry sees his own girlfriend drive
by with a different mouse, with a "Just Married"
sign on the back of their car, too.
Realizing that life now holds nothing for
him either, Jerry joins Tom on the track,
and the screen fades to black as the sound
of a train whistle approaches.
The end.
Thomas the Tank Engine (The Sad Story of Henry)
Most episodes of the popular children's series
Thomas the Tank Engine are rather cheerful
affairs, usually with Thomas or one of the
other engines learning a valuable lesson after
being stubborn or childish in some way.
In "The Sad Story of Henry," a similar setup
leads to a decidedly dark turn.
The green engine Henry is afraid the rain
will ruin his bright and shiny paint, so he
takes refuge inside a tunnel, and then refuses
to leave it, even after the rain stops.
When logical reasoning, firm orders, and even
brute force fail to budge the silly steam
engine, railway manager and father figure
Sir Topham Hatt finally gives up.
Workers pull up the rails to the tunnel and
lay bricks over the entrance, trapping Henry
inside.
The other engines cheekily whistle at Henry
as they pass, and he becomes extremely lonely
and miserable, and the soot from their smoke
ruins his shiny paint.
As the sad green engine contemplates his unknown
fate, even the narrator, Ringo Starr, gets
in on Henry's public humiliation.
"But I think he deserved his punishment…
don't you?"
That's right, kids: if you misbehave, then
it's completely normal for your parents to
lock you in your room and not let you out.
And if you've been really naughty, they might
never come back.
And then a former Beatle will say you deserved
everything you got.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this other cool stuff we
know you'll love too.